of all of this the transport secretary
grant chaps uh mr shah's good to have
you on the program this morning
a huge amount for us to get through so
let us start perhaps with
the scenes that we've just been
discussing in and around the port of
dover
what measures is the government putting
in place given the
already chaotic scenes that we're seeing
in kent
yeah immediately uh as soon as the uh
french said um perhaps
slightly surprisingly that they would
stop hauliers uh rather than just
uh passengers uh we were in touch with a
group that's known as the
kent resilience forum they're well used
to planning for exactly these kind of
circumstances
uh we'll be opening up manston uh as a
uh
as a lorry park uh today uh and
providing welfare for some of those uh
drivers as well whilst uh very close
contact with the french
uh over what will happen next in terms
of capacity how close
are we to to reaching the uppermost
level of the spaces for holiers of this
time
uh oh a long way away at the moment
because of course as soon as this
happened yesterday
uh messages were sent out uh through
people like the rhode haulage
association logistics uk
to say to julius don't travel to kent
which is of course the key message
hallelujah isn't everybody else
uh the border is closed at the moment so
you won't be able to travel across that
way
it's probably also worthwhile me just
setting out the context um
the kent dover to calais the euro tunnel
what we call the short straights is is
probably about 20
of the goods going to and from um
in and out of the country but it's not
um it's not the mainstay
most goods actually come in and out by
unaccompanied
uh containers and those will continue to
flow we would have expected
perhaps 6 000 lorries just under in kent
today
uh they won't be able to cross but the
other crossings remain open
so what then if any are the concerns
about
shortages particularly as regard regards
food and medicines
well we obviously don't want these um
links to be closed for too long but it's
not unusual for them to be closed and
disruptive there
have been periods of some weeks with um
strikes in the in the past for example
the my ferries strike um some years back
uh there have been other pieces of
industrial uh action
um quite frequently actually in calais
uh most people
uh wouldn't have noticed those things
happening um at all so in the short term
it's not
a a specific problem but of course the
key is to get it resolved
um all the other countries that you've
mentioned who've said look we're
concerned about this new very virulent
variant of the coronavirus um have said
we won't have people traveling to us and
in fairness we've said people shouldn't
travel
anyway at the moment the difference is
that the
french have gone slightly further and
said that hauliers
shouldn't cross either whereas all the
other countries uh have
allowed haul years now i'm in touch with
my opposite number uh in france and
we'll make sure
we're doing everything we can to get
that restarted and in fact they said to
us they want to restart the whole ears
as quickly as possible so are you
anticipating that that that
ban on on hollywood's crossing the
channel lasting any longer than the 48
hours
that the french have suggested well i
very much hope not
as i spoke to my opposite number
jean-baptiste de bajer last night
was speaking again later uh this morning
it's probably worth mentioning that the
majority is as
shown in your film that the majority of
um uh julia's are actually european
audience uh and so uh that indicates
something which is true which is that
they are
exporting more than we are to them so in
a sense
they're backing up they'll back up on
their side and it will be inconvenient
to them
as well so there's there's plenty of
incentive always round to
get this resolved and uh that's what
we'll be trying to do
with the um french who as i say have
gone a step or two further
than other countries um quite rightly
wanting to be
uh i think uh precautionary about their
approach because of the
new very virulent strand of coronavirus
but the reality is that it is probably
elsewhere
already we know it is elsewhere already
we actually
happen to know about the strand uh very
well because we do
a very large amount of the genome
sequencing
for coronavirus i think we've done
nearly half of the total sequencing
in the world and so we're seeing these
variants move
uh and we're tracking it quite quickly
but i think the reality is it will
already be
in other places and it's already been
found in several other european
countries for example
trust secretary just in terms of
perishable goods domestically
uh there must be thousands of tons of
perishables either at dover or
on their waited over or back heading
back home and we've had reports of
you know truck loads full of scottish
longest teams on on their way to the
continent which which will spoil as a
result of
all of this will there be any financial
assistance uh for businesses caught up
yes i should say in this sort of haulier
marketplace um julia's
are quite used to anticipating
disruption that's why actually in your
film there you saw quite a lot of them
were pretty well prepared i saw some
people sort of opening up the
the the sort of supplies that they've
got with them and we'll make sure that
we
take care of those who are parked along
the motorway and operations stack at the
moment
this is not unusual and and quite a lot
of this is anticipated into the system
um just as with all global transit uh
there's always the chance of disruption
in all its different forms so the system
will pretty much
take care of itself as far as those
things are concerned uh goods tend to be
insured
where they're perishable but as i say
the absolute
key is to get this resolved as soon as
possible i'll be speaking again to
uh my opposite number jean baptiste
later this morning
there's a meeting taking place actually
right now uh in europe
about it in order to coordinate
approaches and it's not really
in anybody's particular interest to to
not have haulers be out across
and not least because they are mostly
european uh hauliers
and then the goods are mostly theirs so
they won't want them perishing
any more than we would want the board
closed of course
another perishable on all of our minds
at the moment is the vaccine the fires
are vaccine i understand that we've got
stocks to last us to
till january uh we know that there were
contingency plans drawn up
uh an air corridor perhaps a ferry being
used
are we at the point of triggering those
contingency measures to ensure the
supply of the vaccine
no there's no issue there at all most
vaccine doesn't come via
what's called roro roll on roll off
which is what we're talking about here
in other words it's not usually
accompanied by uh by a driver by a
haulier
it comes on those containers and i just
put this into context there are about
six thousand
vehicles we'd expect just under in dover
today uh probably
uh i would say four thousand would have
gone across from
uh dover just under 2000 on the euro
tunnel
but there's probably something like 32
000 units that will
would have been the daily total so the
vast majority
including uh virtually all the vaccine
actually comes by a container uh and as
you say there are good supplies in
in the meantime so this won't have an
impact on uh the vaccination program
uh and as i say we get this kind of
disruption a surprising amount
bad weather strikes uh over in calais
uh that we've seen disruption many times
before
most most consumers just won't notice uh
that at all in the short term it's
obviously important that we get this
resolve
uh with the french and uh that's what
we'll be working to do today
um minister i don't want to put words
into your wife but but from what you're
saying it appears that you know
consumers should not be expecting to see
shortages of
of goods in the supermarket is that
correct well
the supply chain is pretty uh robust in
as much as
you say you get variations and supply
all the time for the most part people
won't notice it uh we what we need to do
is make sure that the
the short-term issue with all ears
specifically
is resolved but as i've explained it's
not the majority of the market
it's actually a significant minority of
the market that happens to come across
this particular
crossing uh and we've got contingencies
in place
uh for um certainly the what we call the
category one
uh goods like uh medicines and uh and
any emergency uh project uh products so
so from that point of view it it won't
cause a problem um and actually it's
probably worth mentioning because of all
of the
planning for the end of the transition
period uh
which is the end of the the month um
unusually of course
we actually happen to be ready for a
degree of disruption and we're certainly
going to see quite a degree of
disruption today
uh but that means we've got things like
um the manston
uh lorry parking uh available
contingency plans to ensure julius are
looked after
and other things that the kent
resilience forum and others have been
working on for many many years
so we're actually we happen to just for
other reasons i'm related to the vaccine
uh be in the right position to to take
care of things
still minister we all know at this time
of year we all
tend to spend perhaps a little too much
on food and drink i'm wondering given
that there may well be some blips in the
supply chain
whether the advice to people you know
this christmas is perhaps
not to buy that second ham not to go
overboard
uh in terms of fresh fruit and
vegetables that you're picking up at the
supermarket
no as i said i think people just go
about their businesses as
usual as there's no reason to do
anything else um
and uh of of course the the key thing is
to
resolve um any disruption that uh dove
dover and calais as quickly as as
possible and uh
i had a conversation with my opposite
number as i mentioned
where uh he was saying to me look we
want to get this resolved particularly
the haulers
um i think it's fair to say that um
everyone's known that the passenger
side of things people just commuting or
um
travelers uh are likely to be disrupted
for a longer but
our message has been please don't travel
anyway and particularly not from the
tier four
uh area uh but really people should be
staying put
everywhere throughout the country at the
moment so i think it's sort of
that part of it is is uh less
spectacular really
in terms of this uh new mutated strain
of of covet 19 the health secretary
yesterday appeared
to intimate that we might be living
under these more severe restrictions
for months to come is that your
understanding
well look the the main thing is to get
this vaccine
uh fully rolled out and i'm pleased to
say it's been accelerating
um we'll have exact numbers um soon but
it looks like
about a half a million people have had
the first jab
uh in their arms so far that's half a
million the most vulnerable people
in this country and as long as we can
keep that process
accelerating of course we're waiting on
news of other vaccines being approved
but if we do that then that is the clear
and obvious route
um out of um these restrictions uh and
uh and and the trajectory is there to do
it so we're hoping that
uh perhaps by easter we're all in a
better position but we've seen many
times with coronavirus it's often
not an entirely predictable straight
line so i do caveat that by saying
you know um we this this is something
that
the virus is something that only
individuals can
help control by keeping and maintaining
that distance and particularly with this
new
virulent variant of the virus which uh
is more easily spread um than the
versions before
but but with the health secretary
describing the situation
in london and the southeast as as out of
control
isn't it now time to consider putting
the rest of the country
into tier iv we know that it has been
detected
in every other part of england well
these yeah these are decisions that you
know we have to make
and way up because uh there are you know
people who've
um you know clearly don't want to live
under restrictions which don't apply to
their error or shouldn't reply to their
area in terms of the level of the virus
of that time and so we've got this
principle
of um dealing with it on a more
localized basis
and i think that's the the right
approach to follow but it
really depends on people following it so
if you want to make sure your area
stays in one of the lower tiers and
doesn't end up
in tier 4 like where i am the only way
to achieve that
is to respect the fact that the virus
will spread in one simple way
when we are all in contact with each
other and what we have to do is
maintain that space from each other and
when we do that it stops the virus from
spreading
so obviously we will have to react to
whatever the virus
does and what the science is showing but
it is in some senses and
literally in people's hands sure i i
don't know that you have to go so this
well i promise to be the last question
just in terms of of people getting
together at christmas
we have half you know we've got
countries all around the world telling
us that people are banned from traveling
to the uk to their country
and at the same time you can drive an
hour out of london and on christmas day
meet up with two other households i mean
isn't now the time
to review once again the christmas
bubble
and of course whether or not the rest of
the country should should immediately be
put into tier four i mean people will be
calling out for that
well let me absolutely correct that you
cannot drive an hour out of london and
go and meet those families
i was merely saying that there is a
there is a location an hour away from
where i'm standing right now where three
households can get together
well look i'm outside london i'm in
hertfordshire but uh i i can't i'm in
tier four
uh i can't meet my my my family and um
you know we're we're gutted i haven't
seen you know parts of my family for uh
for the whole year
um and every family will be very sad
about what's happening this this
christmas but i think it's better to
have those restrictions in place
now uh than and live to see another
christmas um
and uh look in other areas of the
country the
the rates are lower so it is it is um
sensible to have
a response which respects that but and
we've seen this before
it we need to make sure that we're all
respecting the fact that the virus has
no boundaries and it will take advantage
of close human contact
so please be very sensible on christmas
day if you're not in a tier 4
area you're in one of the other areas
just one day
keep plenty of ventilation make sure you
maintain your space and let's keep each
other safe
minister i apologize i said it was going
to be the last question but breaking
news has just occurred and
the danish transport minister has said
that flights from britain to denmark are
to be suspended for
for 48 hours starting at 10 o'clock
and we're going to see this again and
again and again aren't we over the next
24 hours countries around the world
insisting that we
we don't travel there that's absolutely
right but bear in mind that people
shouldn't be traveling
anyway so that's the first thing to say
and secondly
that as i mentioned earlier because we
do so much of the genome
sequencing i think we've done 43 45
percent of all of
corona worldwide of all the coronavirus
sequencing
we are seeing these mutations and
they've been thousands of them by the
way this
latest uh mutation is is uh just happens
as we've discovered to appear to be
uh more transmittable up to 70 more
transmittable
but so we're probably seeing them faster
but many countries
uh will already um have this variant in
in their country so
i think this is a precautionary measure
that uh the countries will be taking
uh but uh i'd say that they'll probably
in the end uh discover that they also
need to
uh be cautious because of the situation
domestically as i say right now
people should be staying put they
shouldn't be traveling anyway
uh and uh as a result um the really the
key thing is to resolve the paulia's
issue and that is specific to france
uh only well i appreciate the early
christmas present of an extra couple of
minutes of your time
grant chaps thanks for joining us on the
program this morning thank you